Violin skulls and the most popular social
networks by country.
It's episode 51 of IMG!
Our Sun is big, like really, really big.
Take a look at this photo of the transit of Venus.
Brady Haran pointed this out to me.
Venus is pretty big.
Almost the size of Earth, but the Sun in this
photo is huge and to put it in perspective,
in this photo the Sun is 67 million miles
further away from us.
But more seriously, what colour is the Moon?
I mean, it's easy to think that the Moon is
just a bright, white silvery grey.
But a lot of that brightness is an illusion,
caused by the fact that the Moon is brighter
than everything around it.
In fact, the Moon only reflects 12% of the
light that hits it from the Sun, which means
the Moon is quite dim.
In fact, it's about the same colour as asphalt,
which means that if you were to put the Moon
and Earth in equal illumination, the Moon
would look like this.
And if you follow @tweetsauce, last week you
would have seen how shallow the oceans are
compared to the radius of the Earth.
If you were to take all the water on Earth
and collect it into a single ball, it would
only be this large.
Mountains and valleys on Earth's surface are
even more puny compared to its overall size.
If you were to take the Earth and shrink it
down to the proportions of a pool ball, the
Earth would be smoother than an actual pool
ball.
But I guess what really matters is that you
should be careful kissing these lips.
And in case of trouble, call on these superhero
lips to save the day.
Nicholas Night's "Social network" series makes
Facebook a bit more real.
This one is called "Joining a group."
"Reached a new high score in Mafia Wars."
"Only some friends see you."
And "Being a fan of."
Now, a few days ago on Reddit, this giant
collection of Facebook timeline covers showed up.
You've got Tetris, fencing, funny walks,
states of matter and more.
Reddit also showed me that with the right
positions and camera angle, you can hide not
one, but two extra people.
Moving on.
On a secluded Mexican island a local man
has been decorating trees with people.
Baby people.
But in Morocco the trees are just full of
climbing goats.
Oh and these woods?
There's a hidden face.
See if you can find the face, but be careful.
Post-It notes can be decoration,
like building-sized decorations.
Or just hang yourself off a building by lying
on top of it and looking up at your reflection.
Robert The carves old books into elaborate shapes.
And this artist stacks and crams book pages,
magazines and newspapers into amazing designs,
including people.
Here's a barn that's actually a converted
water tower.
And if you're afraid your beard might fall
off, you better grow a beard strap.
If you're wondering why all of these animals
are so satisfied, the answer is simple.
Animals are using  the Internet.
Not a fan of animals?
Well, suit yourself.
Expect along with the reflection that looks
like it says something else.
And sculptures love escaping.
In Japan, KitKats are much more diverse.
They've got flavours like pumpkin, potato,
sweet corn, even watermelon and salt.
Mashable shared a diverse collection of geeky cufflinks.
QR codes, typewriter keys, floppy disks and likes.
Now for something less diverse, look at your zipper.
Chances are it says "YKK."
90% of zippers in the world are made by the
YKK group.
Keep being saucy.
And as always,
thanks for watching.